ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ไปเรื่อยๆกลับมาเจอกับลูกปลา
ครูหญิงนาและครูฟ้าและครูหญิงหอค่า
วีดีโอระดับอะไรคะครูฟ้าวีดีโอระดับ
บีกินเนอร์ค่ะดีกินน่อคลาสนะคะ
นิสัยและ
ครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันนี้วันศุกร์วันศุกร์
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่ 28 บาทเดือน
อะไรคะ
เดือนมกราคม
อาชีพตอะไรคะปีพตต
AE คศอะไรคะ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะ 202 แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวัน
พฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 27 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วัน
เสาร์ค่ะ
วันเสาร์ที่เท่าไหร่นะคะวันเสาร์ที่
29 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  02 สองขาแล้ววันนี้ก็วัน
ศุกร์แล้วแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครู
ฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
เที่ยง
กี่นาทีคะ
17 นาทีค่ะเที่ยง 17 นาทีเนาะของครูฟ้า
ก็เป็นเวลากลางวัน
กลางวันแล้วคุณผู้หญิงกี่โมงแล้วคะครู
หญิงก็เป็นเวลาเที่ยงคืนเที่ยงคืน
27 นาทีค่ะเที่ยงคืน 17 นาทีนของผู้หญิง
เป็นเวลากลางคืนกลางคืนมีง่วงไหมคะผู้
หญิงง่วงเฮ้ยนิดหน่อยค่ะคุณฟ้าเหนื่อยว่ะ
in เวลากลางคืนเนี่ย
ต้องหายไปไหนหรอกหากลาง
ไม่ง่วงแต่ว่าก็รู้ว่าค่ะ
ดูอาผู้หญิงกลัวในครั้งหน้าจะ
กลัวงูผี
กับอุปกณ์
ผีหรอ
เนี่ยผี
ผีนักเรียนไม่คะเมื่อไหร่รู้จัก
อะไรบ้างคะ
เพราะว่ากลางซื้อเนี้ยกลางคืนเนี่ยพระ
อาทิตย์ใช่ไหมพระอาทิตย์เนี่ยไม่มี
ผีจะแบบเนี้ยผู้ชาย
กูไม่
เอาไปดูเดอะนันมั้ยเห้ยเอา
รู้ว่าเหรอผู้หญิงไอ้ฟ้า
กิ่งต้องปิดตาเราจะแบบดูนิดหน่อยไหมว่า
กลัวผีค่ะครูฟ้าครูฟ้ามีหาพี่พี
ก็กี่น่ารักๆผู้หญิงขี่แคสเตอร์โอเคค่ะ
ไม่กลัวแต่ว่าเอางูรูปที่แล้ว
ไม่เอากับผู้ฟ้า
กลัวกลัว
ผีน้าครูฟ้ามั้ยกลัวผีหรอ
กลัวค่ะผู้หญิง
ครูฟ้ากลัวแต่ดูรูปโอเค
ครูฟ้าครูผีแต่ครูฟ้า
ชอบผีค่ะ
สุภาโชคผี
ทรูหญิงเนี่ยกลัวผีแล้วก็
ไม่ชอบผีค่ะไม่เอา
ดูตัวผีมากๆฟ้าเนี่ยกลัวผีแต่ว่าดูซีรีส์
ผีโอเคดูหนังผีวาดขอบดูอาลีวูดหนัง
ฮอลีวูด ln อะไร
นั่นน่ะว่า
คอนจูริ่งหนังผี
ว่าชอบดูหนังผีมากค่ะแตกก็กลัวกลัวอ่ะงู
การครูหญิงเนี่ยกลัวผีดู
ไม่ได้ถ้าดู
[เพลง]
ดูหน่อยเพราะว่ากลัวใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ย
กลัวผีแล้วครูฟ้ากลัวอะไรอีกไหมคะมีอะไร
ที่ครูฟ้าเห็นแล้วแบบตัวแบบนี้นักเลงโยน
ใส่แล้วฟ้าแบบ
กลัวมากๆมีไหม
มีอยู่ 1 อย่างค่ะ
อะไรอ่ะมีธูปอ่ากลัว
จิ้งจก
เปิดจิ้งจกได้ไหมคะที่ Google
ไม่อ่ะ
ไม่ได้
บอกว่าอะไรจริงจบครูฟ้าหลับตาได้นะคะนี่
ค่ะอันนี้คือจิ้งจกเนาะจิ้งจกเนี่ยตัว
เล็กๆๆก็เป็นเล็กมากนะคะประมาณนี้นะ
ประมาณนี้นะคะจริงจบ
จิ้งจกเนี่ยอยู่ที่บ้าน
หัวขวดด้านจะมีจิ้งจกครูฟ้าครูหญิงถามได้
ไหมคะทำไมครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำไมนะทำไมทำไมครู
ฟ้ากลัวจิ้งจก
เพราะว่าตอนเด็กๆนะคะตอนเด็กตอนดึกคุณครู
ฟ้าอายุเท่าไหร่
โอ่ง
ประมาณ 8-9 มั้งถึง 4 คู่ฟ้าเนาะครูฟาร์ม
ประมาณ 8-9 ขวบทำให้จันทร์ไม่ชัวร์นะว่า
กี่ครูแต่ว่าครูฟานเนี่ย
นั่งเล่นอยู่ใช่ไหมเล่นคอมพิวเตอร์อยู่
ที่ห้องนอนค่ะห้องนอนเนี่ยห้องน้องฟ้าก็
จะมีคอมพิวเตอร์หมอนั่งเล่นเกม
อยู่น้ำห้องนอน
นั่งเล่นเกมนะคะแล้ว
คุณแม่ก็เนี่ยคุณแม่เนี่ยทำอาหารอยู่ที่
ห้องครัวทำอาหารเออทำต้มยำกุ้งสปาเก็ตตี้
ใหญ่อย่าทำอาหารอยู่ที่ห้องครัวเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยคุณแม่ก็เรียกครูฟ้าค่ะป้า
และเมื่อกินข้าวคุณแม่ทำอาหารเสร็จสมัย
คุณแม่บอกป๊าป๊ากินข้าว
กูมาก็โอเคกินข้าวเขาก็เลยเดินเดินเดิน
จากห้องนอนนะคะเดิน
เดินไปถึงบันไดค่ะขอ
สมัยใด
ก็เดินลงบันได
ต้องอนาคตฟ้าลงยังไงกันเนี่ย
อะไรอ่ะเอาเอาแบบประมาณน้องกูมาก็ลง
บันไดแล้วทำไมคะ
ระหว่างตอนที่ครูฟ้าเดินลงบันไดนาอยู่ๆก็
มี
อะไรไม่รู้นะคะกระโดดมาเกาะ
ขาหมูฟ้าใส.มีผู้หญิงคอขาได้ไหมได้ค่ะของ
ไข่ไม่ได้
ภาษาขาตรงนี้นะคะ
มีอะไรไม่รู้หรอกขาครูฟ้า
มันแบบ
นี้มายังนิ่ม
กูฟ้าเห็นไหมอะไร
มันคือจิ้งจกค่ะนักเรียนไม่ตอนแรกตอนแรก
ที่ฟ้ากำลังเดินเดินเดินแล้วมีอะไรเกาะ
ครูบารุเห็นมั้ยอะไรตอนแรกไม่เห็น
ไม่เห็นจะพอมีอะไรมาเกาะขาสมาธิค่ะกบมอง
ก็เลยบอกอะไรแล้วก็เห็นว่าเป็นจิ้งจกนะฮะ
เป็นคู่ฟ้าจับไหมได้จับจิ้งจกมั้ยไม่กู
บ้าตกใจมากๆก็เลยไม่นี้เนี่ย Google
Live มั้ยใช่กำลังคือกระโดดแบบ
กระโดดนะไม่เข้าใจไหมอันนี้เป็นขาแบบแม่
ครัวก็เรียกแม่ครับ
และจิ้งจกมันก็วิ่งอ่ะวิ่งแบบที่ขาตึงๆๆๆ
แล้วก็แปะอยู่ที่พื้น
พื้น
แล้วฟ้าก็เหยียบ
ขอก็คือจริงตบตูดสีแดงนะสีแดงเป็นจิ้งจกๆ
ๆแล้วก็
ผู้ฟ้าก็เหยียบบอกว่าเหยียบ
ดูเค้าฉกค่ะ
ล็อค Hi
โอ้ยกลัวมากตั้งแต่ครูฟ้าอายุ 8 ขวบจนถึง
ตอนนี้ 2022
ไม่ใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าก็กลัวจิ้งจกถ้าครูหญิง
มีจิ้งจกแล้วมีจิ้งจกแล้วก็
มาก็จะช็อคไปเลยอ๋อ
ก็ฟ้ากลัวมากๆใช่ไหมกลัวจิ้งจกมากๆกลัว
มากค่ะแต่ว่าที่บ้านความมีจิ้งจกนะ
มีจิ้งจกอยู่มีคนไม่เห็นโอเค
ไม่เห็นโอเค
ยันหากูบ้าก็กลัวจิ้งจก
แล้วก็กลัวผี
แต่ชอบนะชอบขี่ด้วยแบบไม่ชอบจิ้งจกนะคะ
ไม่ชอบจิ้งจกงูต้องไปชอบ
กลัวมากครูหญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงกลัวอะไรไหม
คู่หญิงกลัวค่ะกลัวจิ้งจก
และยิ่งคือ
งูผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่เปิดนะคะกิ้งกือ
เปิดใน Google ดูไม่ได้ที่นี่นะคะแขนใช่
ไหมมีคนเนี่ยแบบ
กิ้งตื่นมาจะเปิดให้ดูนะฮะเออกิ้งกือ
เนี่ยนะคะมันจะเป็น
จ้างอันนี้ตัวเดียวโอเคนะกิ้งกือนะใช่ค่ะ
มันเป็นสีแดงๆงั้นล่ะค่ะ
เนี่ยอ่ะค่ะครูฟ้าพอแล้ว
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนไม่เจ็บนะโรงเรียนเราจะคุย
อีกไม่เกณฑ์หมดหรือยังคะโอเคคุยไม่เอา
เห็นไม่ได้หรอกเออกลัวมากๆ
คือผู้หญิงไม่แจกหรอกทำไมมากกว่าไม่ชอบ
ค่ะกลัวตัวแบบผู้หญิงไม่เหมือนกูฟ้านะกู
ฟ้านะเดินแล้วขอจบตกแล้วก็กลัวแต่ผู้หญิง
เนี่ยฟังใช่มั้ยฟัง Sorry
อะไรอ่ะ
วิทยุอาหารฟ้าอะทีวีใช่ไหมฟังจาก TV แล้ว
กันเป็นทีวีน้องเป็น New นะเป็นข่าวที่
ทีวีน้องเกี่ยวกับกิ้งกือนักฟังฟังฟัง
แล้วก็ที่นี่ใช่ไหมมันก็คิดคิดคิดๆแล้วก็
แบบก็คือแล้วก็กลัว
เป็นคนมีแบบวะอีเมลจิ้นเหรออีเมลจิเนชั่น
Story แบบผู้หญิงอ่ะเค้าอยากจะทำต้อง
เล่าใช่ไหมคะเป็นผู้หญิงที่ว่าตอนนั้นน่ะ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยนั้นผู้หญิงนั่นจะอยู่ประมาณ
แบบต้องคั่วกับภูฟ้า 6 ขวบเด็กๆใช่ไหม
แล้ว Sorry ก็คือผู้หญิงเนี่ยผู้หญิง
เนี่ยเขาเขาแต่ของใหญ่อย่างเงี้ยค่ะท้อง
ใหญ่แต่เพราะไปโรงพยาบาลปีบ่มีบ่โรง
พยาบาล
โรงพยาบาลเนี่ยก็จะมีคุณหมอ
ใช่ไหมคุณหมอเนี่ยคุณหมอคุณหมอก็มีมีดมี
มีดแล้วก็ผ่าท้องผู้หญิงแล้วก็ข้างในอ่ะ
ไม่มีเบบี้เอ้าคือกินคือกินข้าว
ทำไมมีขี้เกลือ
ผู้หญิงไม่ใช่คนกรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะที่บ้าน
น่ะ
ที่บ้าน
บ้านที่ชลบุรีก็มีกิ้งกือกิ้งกือที่คือ
เยอะไงแล้วแบบมาฟังแล้วก็เห็นไหมฝั่งแล้ว
ที่นี่ก็คิดแล้วก็มีภาพออกกินกลืนจริงคือ
กินคือคนลูกแล้วอย่า
กลัวว่าพี่กลัวกลิ้งคือมากๆ
ๆ
หัวกลัวคุยฟ้าเปิด Google ใช่ไหมแล้วก็ดู
กิ้งกือคุยก็แบบดูไม่ได้ดูเสร็จแล้วแบบคน
ลุกขึ้นในที่นี่เนี่ยนี่มีขนขนขนหนูไม่
เอากลัว
แล้วถ้าไม่ใช่กิ้งกือผู้อย่างกลัวอะไรอีก
คะผู้หญิงกลัวปลิงค่ะ
เดี๋ยวครูฝาเปิดให้ดูว่าคู่หญิงไม่เอานะ
คะปลิงแต่มันจะสีดำๆเนาะ
ผู้หญิงลับตานะฮะมาขาลิงอ่ะลิงเห็นไหม
แป๊บนึงเพิ่งจะลืมตานะอันนี้คือปลิงนัก
เรียนอะไรค่ะ
กริ่งนามิฤทธิ์ครูฟ้ามีผู้สาวใหม่กลัวใช่
ไหมไม่หาไม่
ลิงอันนี้นะคะมันจะอยู่ในอยู่ใน
อยู่ในน้ำมาค่ะเนี่ยสมมติว่าเราปลูกข้าว
ใช่ไหมปลูกข้าวข้าวที่คนไทยกินอ่ะถูกข้าว
เนี้ยมันทีมันจะมีน้ำตรงนี้มีน้ำน้ำน้ำ
มันก็จะมีปลิงปลิงอยู่หรือว่าแม่น้ำแม่
น้ำเหมือนแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาแม่น้ำ
มิสซิสซิปปีน้องแม่น้ำเทมส์เนี่ยแม่น้ำใน
ไทยอ่ะค่ะมันก็จะมีปลิงแล้วตอนครูหญิง
เด็กๆเมื่อก่อนบ้านที่ชลบุรีเนี่ยก็มี
แล้วแบบกันอย่างเงี้ยแล้วมันก็นิ่มๆนิ่มๆ
แล้วมึง
คิดว่าปลิงเหมือนกิ้งกือ
ฉันไม่ชอบใช่ตัวแล้วก็เปลี่ยนก็คิดอ่ะ
เหมือนและก็เลยไม่ชอบไม่ชอบอะไรที่มัน
นิ่มๆแล้วก็แบบอย่างเงี้ย
ผู้หญิงก็เลยไม่ผู้หญิงกลัวคือเห็น
เห็นแล้วไม่โอเคใช่ไหมโอเคไม่โอเคดูรูป
สมัยดูรูปใน Google อินเตอร์เน็ตก็ไม่
โอเคกลัวกลัวมากๆ
ขอ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยกลัวผีใช่ไหมกลัวจิ้งกือกลัว
ปลิงเนาะครูฟ้าเนี่ยกลัวผีกลัวนิ่งจบในหา
เลาะครูฟ้ากลัวอะไรอีกไหมคะหรือว่าหมด
แล้ว
ครูฟ้า
ครูวาปี
ที่เกิด
กลัวอะไร
นะนี่ไม่มีครูหัวใจชาติครัวอ่า
อะไรนะมันชื่ออะไรนะแมงสาบไหมคะ
[เพลง]
ไม่กลัวหนวด
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่กลัวนะแมงสาปใจแต่พอดีผู้
หญิงจะมาผู้หญิงไทยมากๆเนี่ยกลัว
แมลงสาบแมลงสาบเห็นแม่แบบ
ไม่กลัวแต่ว่าแมลงสาบมันวิ่งนะจะมีแม่จะ
บินแผ่นดินผู้หญิงก็ไม่โอเคนะไม่เอาเข้า
มาแลงสาบดินประเทศคลิปหน้าเรียนครูฟ้าถ้า
แมลงสาบเดินกูฟ้าไม่กลัวเจอแต่ถ้าแมลงสาบ
บิน
ครูฟ้า
บินผ่านฟ้าฟ้ากลัวๆ
ตั้งปลุกผีก็รู้กูแบบ
สิลิงค์มาสิริม
ชายๆเราอันนี้ก็เป็นสิ่งที่ครูหญิงมันก็
ครูฟ้ากลัวนะคะไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนกลัวอะไร
น้องก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะบ้านะที่มี
กลัวอะไรกลัวผีไหมคะ
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะเนาะก็เขาเม้นบอกเราได้เนาะวันนี้
เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้าเนาะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะดีค่าา